Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on.
Guys. This is Rob and we are picking back up again with dark Knights and metal,
but this time we're covering the Lobo one-shot and anybody who knows anything
about DC comics knows that Lobo is the most 1990s character ever.
And this story, I'm not even gonna lie to you guys.
This story is a descent into absolute madness.
This initially picks up in a bar, right? Just kind of six months ago,
right before seemingly all this,
this where at least when this dark nights metal stuff kind of kicked off. Right?
So, uh, following perpetuates takeover is basically when this happens. And, uh,
we initially picked up with Lobel in this part.
And of course getting off at the bartender because the bartender's not getting
them any more drinks only for us to find out the reason why the bartender can't
get him more drinks is because he ripped off the bartender's arms and beat
everybody in the bar to death with them.
And so that's why the bartender can't get him any drinks. So
the other part of that is that he was here originally for the bounty,
but he killed the guy in the bar before anybody could tell him,
or before you could tell Lobo who he actually was,
or him basically beat everybody to death before they could tell him who he was.
So Lobo basically went into a rage, which is kind of normal, right?
That's what Lobo does, right? When you're basically a parody of Wolverine,
that's essentially what you do. You just go into to arbitrary Rangers,
for reasons that don't really make any sense. Cause you know,
that's what will rain does? And he grabs the body.
And of course he ends up being kind of yanked away. Now, when he janked away,
he's basically pulled by what looks like a version of Lobo, right?
Like this just huge gaudy version of Lobo. This guy is technically he's.
He's like the, the, what is it? The Batman who frags that's a stupid name.
Would you call him bat Lobo? Well, that's a much better name, right?
So like we're gonna call them bat Lobo. Like Batman becomes Lobo.
That's basically what we're going to call him.
But essentially it's one of the craziest things.
Because as soon as Lobo goes to punch this guy,
he immediately gets the upper hand, takes Lobo down. And that's it.
Now one thing to understand about this guy about Lobo's character,
this is a guy that can go toe to toe with Superman.
This guy is not someone to be scoffed at, right?
He's not some kind of small time guy.
The other thing about this is that Batman becoming Lobo basically happened in a
dark dark universe,
somewhere in the dark multiverse where Bruce Wayne injected himself with Barney
and DNA.
And it essentially gave him all the strength and the healing factor of Lobo
combined with all the skills and the fighting powers of Batman.
So like literally he's able to take on Lobo quite readily, right? I mean,
just able to, to, to get the upper hand on this guy quick, fast,
and in a hurry and the fights, not much of a big, long drawn out fight.
One of the other things that happens is that where he's, he's, uh,
he's fighting off against,
but we end up finding out that Lobo is actually playing possum, right?
He's just kind of faking how weak he is.
And that's one of the crazy things that goes on here is because in this Batman
who frags right, this bat Lobo's reality,
we don't really know if Lobo in the traditional sense ever actually existed.
Right. It's just his RNA and DNA. We don't really know if that's the case.
I mean, presumably it is right because he got the DNA from somewhere,
but Lobo actually ends up grabbing his own, you know,
battering chain thing and throws it into the, in his stomach.
And then suddenly Lobo's, uh, LinkedIn, uh, yanked away get again, right.
He snatched away again. And when that happens,
of course he arrives in front of Lex Luther.
Now this is kind of explains on the backend.
How is that during the events of dark nights metals?
So basically the first four issues that we've covered so far wide as it Lobo's
on some kind of a special quest, we didn't really know what was going on. Right.
We just kind of got these cutaways where we we'd show Lobo just doing a thing.
And we wouldn't really get a whole lot of explanation.
We knew that he was communicating with Lex Luther and whatever's his,
whatever his mission was had to do with somebody, Lex Luther sent him for it,
but we didn't really know anything besides that bright.
So it was cool for us to get this kind of explanation here. Well,
the reality is that Lobo has been sent on a mission by Lex Luther to basically
capture what's called death metal and death metal.
This actual material here is essentially a material that can rewrite all of
reality.
But this is one of the issues that I'm sort of having with with dark nights,
metal, dark nights, metal is a fun story. It's a good event,
but it kind of feels like things are just being invented out of thin air for the
sake of telling a story, right. Just kind of being invented on the fly, right?
Just like moment, like this is not really planned out.
It's just kind of just things being, being invented out of nowhere.
Like a lot of this stuff just kind of feels too convenient if that makes any
sense. But the other part of this is that it is called death metal, right?
So it makes sense that there would be some kind of material out there called
death metal that would have the power to rewrite and recreate all of reality as
the wielders sees fit. Right. To basically recreate it. All right.
And then that's, what's kind of nuts.
Here is something that you don't usually see in DC comics,
which I think is what's really kind of getting to me,
that's something that you see in Marvel all the time, right?
The infinity infinity gauntlet, the cosmic cube, the cosmic regulator,
you see it all the time when like somebody achieves a level of power where they
have the ability to recreate all of reality on a whim, right? I mean the,
and the not even just the universe, the whole multi-verse,
sometimes I'm not really used to seeing that in DC comics,
somebody attaining an artifact that makes them so incredibly powerful.
They can control and manipulate the entirety of the multi-verse itself. Now,
again,
I'm not nearly as well versed in DC comics as I am in Marvel when it comes to
like a lot of the more obscure nitty gritty things,
stuff like that because outside of the infinity gauntlet,
if I walk up to the average person on the street and I say, Hey,
what's the casket of ancient winters or what is the heart of the universe?
They're not going to be able to give me an answer because they're not going to
know whether this is not something that they're familiar with. And so, um,
you know, with, with BC,
I'm not nearly as well versed in their intricate artifacts as I am with Marvel,
but I'm not aware of anything that's not powerful in DC. So it feels wholly new.
But in order to go on this mission, Lobo is like,
I need some kind of transportation.
And that's when one is basically given to them by Lex Luther, right?
Like his space bike as though,
as soon as he gets his baseball IQ basically takes off only for us to find out
that, uh, that the Batman, I guess, the, the Batman who frogs right,
is still very much awake and is basically on the,
on the mission or going on the mission of tracking down Lobo. Now,
at this point, we switch over to us technically the second part,
and the reason why this matters is because this Lobo comic is not written by one
person. So you've got Frank Cherry, who's writing this first part.
You've got Becky Cloonan who writes the last part or the second part.
And then you've got Sam Humphreys who writes the third part,
but neither one of these parts are exceedingly long, right?
Instead they're maybe nine or 10 pages each. And so we switch over to a,
to the second part here and we've got Lobo on black Hawk Island out in the
middle of nowhere. If you guys recall Blackhawk Island is where the,
the original dark nights metal event all kind of kicked off in terms of the
realization that like everything's sort of popping off.
So it's kind of cool to see us return this, to know your place,
but in the middle of that Lobo ends up facing off against what looks, I mean,
technically it's called black Monday, but it's like Solomon Grundy, Batman.
So in any event,
one of the things I kind of keep in mind when it comes to Lobo is that he is
kind of an idiot and he's easy to manipulate in a lot of different ways.
And that's one of the things that Lobo says, right?
Lobel kind of builds on him and it's just kind of like, you know,
you're basically a goof, right? I mean, you're an evil Batman, right?
So you're not necessarily weak, but like, think about it, right?
They put you on this Island by yourself to keep an eye out for anybody who
stumbles along,
they put you here because nobody likes you and you don't have any friends.
Nobody wants to be your friend. And in fact,
Lobo almost kind of starts befriending Solomon Grundy when he's like,
we're actually not that different. You and I, right?
Like I don't really have any friends. Now,
the reason why Lobo has no friends is because he killed everybody on his home.
Planet, killed all the killers, his entire race, and, uh,
is basically a bounty Hunter. Who's just kind of a Dick, nonetheless, you know,
that's kind of why he doesn't have any friends. Uh,
just something to keep in mind, guys, if you want friends, don't be a Dick.
Nobody wants to be friends with a Dick. Unless, well, there is that one guy,
every circle of friends has that one guy who is kind of a Dick, but he's ours,
right. He's our friend, but he's allowed to be that be that guy because he's,
he's our friend. Right. And how to get away with murder. It's Asher that,
guy's hilarious. I love that show. Uh, I'm a,
why sort started talking about that in any event, getting back on track,
you wind up having Lobo and you end up having, you know, Solomon Grundy,
or at least Solomon Grundy kind of defeated. And then from there, uh,
he ends up traveling through this,
this plays with all these different artifacts and ends up finding a box to
supposed to contain the death metal. Right. And he's like, man,
like I can't just simply be lying around like this, you know? And he's like,
okay.
So like when he finds it is simply not there and that's what Hawk man shows up.
He's like,
you really don't think that I would have taken this artifact that had the
ability to rewrite all of reality and just left it sitting in a room somewhere.
Right? I mean, no, it doesn't work that way.
It was a terrible idea to do that. Instead he had various notebooks,
all the notes that he taken since the Dawn of time.
If you guys remember the adventures of Carter hall from dark nights, metal,
when he was thrust back to the very beginning of time and basically started
writing through all these different,
these different notes and everything that he knew about the events of the metal
and all that kind of stuff.
He'd been basically documenting everything that he knew about death metal as
well. And then in turn, all those different notebooks were stolen.
But what he did is he managed to hide the, uh, the death metal itself. Right.
He managed to keep it hidden away in a place where nobody would be able to find
it except for Carter hall himself. And so when he's talking to Lobo, initially,
he doesn't want to hand it over. Right. He doesn't want to give it to Lobo,
but Luvo actually makes this really, really cool.
There's this really cool argument here.
What he basically says is that he's not really here because he's tempted by the
power of death metal and he wants to use it for his own ends.
That's not why he's looking to attain it.
He's looking to attain it because it's a mission he was sent on. Right.
He's just doing it for the bounty. And that's kind of an interesting thing.
One of the funny things about Lobo is that he's not really a guy who focuses on
trying to attain absolute power. Right. He just cares about the cash, right.
Cash money, right. Moolah, cheddar. That's all he really cares about. Right.
Just, just, just cheese. That's all he cares about is just getting cheese.
And a lot of people use that phrase anymore.
What phrase do you guys use in relation to like money, right. Like stacks.
Right. I don't know what, what phrase you guys use anymore.
Mariah says it's called stacking your coins. Is that true? Cause if it is,
it's like the least cool thing ever, right? Like, yeah man. Yeah.
I'm stuck in them coins. That doesn't sound remotely cool. Nonetheless,
right in the middle of this whole thing,
because of the fact that Hawk man is kind of like, okay,
so like he doesn't want anyone to use it for absolute power.
Maybe a Lobo really is the best person to put it, you know,
put this in the hands of he's exceedingly strong, he's got a healing factor.
He's not easily defeated. Right.
So maybe he really is the best choice because he's essentially Superman.
Who's also like a terrible human being or a terrible,
a terrible being out there. But at the same time,
doesn't want to use it for absolute power. Right.
He's just going to hand it over to whoever sent him on this mission,
which is probably for a good cause. I don't know. I mean,
I guess Hakman's kind of assuming,
but in the middle of all that they're suddenly met by the return of bat Lobo.
Who's,
who's flying this amazing looking bat wing and just raining down to hell fire
on this place. Now a portal also ends up opening that that Hawkman created,
but he doesn't really know where it goes to.
And so instead where he tells hoc where he tells Lobo, go through,
they're all hold them off, Lobo, snatches up and says, Nope,
you're coming with me. And when they pass through the portal,
the end up inside Jim ward. Right. And so from there,
the Lobo ends up basically using this, this device to kind of recreate reality,
right. Or, or at least seemingly recreate reality.
We're not really given a full on explanation here because somehow or another,
we basically ended up transitioning from Jim world into, uh, into this, this,
you know, Lobo land.
And the only real kind of transition that we get here is when Lobo kind of opens
the box and it says like, this is the part I've been waiting for. Right.
So seemingly he basically created like this whole dimension where everybody
seems to basically be a version of Lobo, right? Like you've got like a Lobos,
a Superman story, you've got a Lobo Batman story.
You got a Lobo wonder woman's story. But in the middle of all that,
while he's kind of doing all this stuff,
this suddenly he's met by the arrival of brainiac and Brittany EG of course,
managed to escape the confines of, uh, of Perpetua and justice league number 56.
I don't know if anybody read that, honestly,
we don't really need you to understand it.
We can just say brainiac was locked away.
At some point he basically ended up escaping what Propecia was thrown was
destroyed, done. Right. That's really all you need to know,
but he's essentially here for the purpose of trying to get a Lobo to hand the
device over to over to him. And the idea is that if Lex Luther, you know, Alexa,
they were basically told him that if Lex ever,
ever ended up going missing to ensure that Lobo handed over the device to
brainiac right now, this is suspicious at best or as Mariah. Uh, Mario says,
this is sus I am, I'm getting terribly off topic. Gordon's going to have,
Gordon is going to have a job sorting all this stuff out,
trying to figure out what stays and what goes. But, uh, in any event, what,
what Lobo actually ends up doing is kind of warping reality to a degree.
Now here's the funny thing about this.
This is very reminiscent of the old captain Britain story.
When he first encountered,
imagine Jasper's or really the second time they fought when he fought Jim
Jasper's from the main Marvel universe where he kept snapping his fingers.
And all of reality just kept changing on a whim, like in the blink of an eye.
Reality just kept changing every single time he snapped,
it was something different. And, uh, Kevin Britton was just wildly outclassed,
right? It was kind of cool, which is,
I'm hoping we see something like that during the tennis swords event from
Marvel. But, um, he basically kind of ends up, you know,
basically poking fun at brainiac makes them look like, uh, Mrs. Tibbs, right?
His, uh, his miss, his fourth grade teacher, but just kind of goofing off,
right.
And making brainiac look like a bit of a buffoon and not really taking any of
this stuff seriously.
But that's when brainiac actually kind of takes a break away from the character
that we're normally used to and says, look like Lobo, you have to pay attention,
right? You are literally a survivor. The last of your kind,
the toughest best ditch in the universe, in your jargon, you've survived alone.
The odds are beyond the bounds of viability, but you beat them by being selfish.
And then you ask this crazy question, like,
what's the difference between jam and jelly and between yeah.
Between jelly and jam. He's like the sugar content. He's like, Ron,
I can't jelly this gun up. You're exhausted.
But he basically like besieged him and he says, look,
this is going to be the biggest test of your survival skills that you are going
to have to be selfish. Your selfishness is your survival. So be selfish with us,
right? Like give me the death metal.
It's the only way that we can possibly live.
And so what ends up happening is you end up having in the middle of this kind of
discussion that suddenly Batman logo pops back up again and basically starts
going on the, going on the offense against Lobo.
This is 1990s commerce guys at this feels chaotic and insane.
This was comics in the 1990s, almost universally across the board.
It was like every 15 year old, every 15 year old bedroom. Right. Just a chaotic,
disorganized mess. That's basically what it was. Right.
Let's basically how this, this whole thing was.
And so because of that with bat Lobo,
kind of getting the upper hand to a degree logo, of course,
having the ability to control this reality basically ends up grabbing bat Lobo
and just kind of sticking it back down basically into, into Lobo land, right?
Like, like get a blast global land in your face. He's like,
and you go and basically like kind of shoves him in there and this little pocket
dimension and kind of keeps the guy locked away right now.
Presumably he can escape at some future point in time. But of course, you know,
Lobo ends up restoring brainiac back to his normal self and then says like the
inflection point approaches, right?
The moment with when existence hangs in the balance,
the key to everything is in your blood. And so Lobo kind of has this idea, okay,
like he's going to pull this wild and crazy stunt. We have no idea what it is,
but seemingly the fate of all reality comes down to the hands of a
death metal, rock music,
crazy dark version of Superman.
Who's probably one of the coolest DC characters ever created.
So with that being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the rod for,
if you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll cut you off.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].